E aí
[Música]
bom então começo a nossa fala né eu
nosso momento juntos trazendo algumas
algumas inquietações que seria
interessante trazer para vocês como pelo
fato de eu conviver com muitas pessoas
no processo de aprendizagem de
transformação eu comecei a perceber
alguma algumas coisas a primeira delas é
que tudo hoje é muito corrido tudo hoje
é muito rápido tudo hoje É muita pressão
e as pessoas elas passam por muitas
etapas da vida e quanto os alunos no
processo de obter a titulação a
graduação a pós-graduação de obtém
aquele certificado aquele diploma
Quantas pessoas no processo de passar e
obter o curso Se Esqueceram de aprender
quero porque delas estarem lá Quantas
pessoas no processo de trabalhar né de
ganhar o seu sustento ela se esquecem do
que elas fazem e de produzir e de
transformar e o quanto que no ato da
gente hoje vencer uma
é de política ou entrar dentro do debate
político a gente esquece de pensar o
Brasil que a gente quer então nos
últimos cinco anos eu tenho desenvolvido
estudos pesquisas como Gilmar comentou
para gente tentar entender o que que tá
acontecendo dentro do Brasil e eu
aprendi quatro lições que eu gostaria de
trazer para vocês e trazendo essas
lições pensando no que a gente é hoje no
que a gente gostaria de ser e como o
mundo é tá E para isso eu adoto é duas
metáforas né duas dois conceitos duas
ideias básicas a primeira delas é do
crescimento né o paradigma do
crescimento do que a gente pensa nós nós
vamos crescer e economia e o segundo é o
desenvolvimento o argumento que eu vou
tentar trazer para vocês o seguinte no
processo de tentar ganhar dinheiro a
gente tá esquecendo do mais importante
que é como a gente vai ganhar dinheiro
todo mundo tão preocupado em ganhar
dinheiro em ter lucratividade que a
essência do crescimento né
e empresas ganhando dinheiro e a gente
se esquece do como a gente tá ganhar
dinheiro de trazer sustentabilidade de
trazer competitividade para os negócios
para as empresas então eu vou estar
desenvolvendo com vocês e vou explicar
cada um desses dois elementos o primeiro
deles é o elemento do crescimento
econômico o que que é crescimento
econômico explicando aí rapidamente
crescimento econômico é hoje A ideia é
que a gente tem mais forte no Brasil
crescimento econômico é a ideia de
empresa ganhando dinheiro empresa ganhar
dinheiro o que que a empresa ganhando
dinheiro imagina em que o mercado tem
demanda as pessoas compram as pessoas
que são comer as pessoas precisam
comprar né então mercado apresenta uma
demanda e as empresas observam em
oportunidade então eu vou lá Entra
naquele mercado e começa a ganhar muito
dinheiro então quando as empresas
começam a perceber que ali tá dando
muito dinheiro começa então a surgir uma
uma ideia de maior oportunidade então
começa
o investimento começa a ter um setor
mais atrativo mais empresas querendo
participar com o aumento da quantidade
de empresas a gente vai então ter ao
momento de oferta de empregos né porque
são mais empresas então mais empregos né
E esses empregos vão gerando mais
oportunidades até chegar a ideia de que
a gente vai ter muitas empresas e a
gente vai chegar no ideal de pleno
emprego que quando tem muita oferta de
emprego no país EA ideia da
lucratividade ela é pautada numa questão
muito simples eu gasto pouco eu recebo
muito né então a ideia a curto prazo é
que tendo muitas empresas ganhando muito
e lucrando muito vai aumentar
arrecadação de impostos vai melhorar a
oferta de trabalho e assim com o
crescimento nós vamos alcançar uma
situação de maior conforto até chegar no
ponto que vai ter tanta oferta de
emprego quem as empresas vão começar a
lutar é para ter os melhores
trabalhadores então
a partir para os trabalhadores então a
ideia do crescimento é garantir uma base
simples que as empresas ganham dinheiro
e como que isso tem sido alcançado em
termos de Brasil primeiro primeiro com a
ideia de que a gente precisa baratear
baratear as empresas Então os curso
muito forte ou já Vamos tornar a empresa
mais barata e com isso o que que
aconteceu aconteceu da gente tornar
folha de salário mais barato como por
meio da reforma trabalhista então a
gente já conseguiu isso a segunda tem
mais uma oferta de mão de obra ou seja
mais pessoas é trabalhando no mercado e
assim com mais trabalhadores né o preço
do trabalho cai porque é mais gente
competindo por um emprego como é que a
gente consegue isso a gente já conseguiu
com a reforma da Previdência Então as
pessoas demoram mais tempo para se
aposentar e conhecer mais gente no
mercado e a terceira Linha de Frente é a
redução de tributos que é hoje uma das
pautas né tornar as empresas mais
baratas em te
há muito tempo de imposto então a ideia
Desse pessoal é fazer tem mais empresas
e trazendo mais empresas com isso o
Brasil cresce Só que essa é uma visão
que a gente pode entender contra pão da
outra que a do desenvolvimento se o
Brasil está pensando em desenvolvi
crescimento lá fora no estrangeiro nos
países do Norte nos Estados Unidos e na
Europa eles pensam em desenvolvimento e
o que que é ideia do desenvolvimento
aqui a gente não pensa em lucratividade
aqui a gente pensa em competitividade e
sustentabilidade e o que que é
competitividade sustentabilidade não é
só a questão de ganhar dinheiro é como
ganhar dinheiro é ser competitivo é ser
o melhor E aí a gente pode colocar uma
contraposição um exemplo muito simples
as empresas brasileiras conseguem
competir com as empresas estrangeiras
nós somos tão bons quanto eles nós temos
uma oferta
Olá boa quanto eles então eles pensam
aqui o lucro não é a o desejo primário
de uma empresa ser competitivo sim ser o
melhor sim e como que a gente faz isso
por meio de três elementos primeiro
diferenciar-se da concorrência ser
melhor que o concorrente segundo seu que
nova é aquele Empresário é aquele
trabalhador que gosta da tecnologia que
entende que a tecnologia é algo que que
facilita a vida então ela abraça e da
tecnologia né E principalmente
investimento em pessoas que é a questão
da produtividade no trabalho então
Observe Enquanto aqui hoje no Brasil a
gente está falando de tornar empregos
mais baratos o que que lá fora eles
querem eles querem tornar os empregos
mais bem remunerados então em conta que
a gente está falando de pagar menos lá
eles querem pagar mais por quê Porque
eles querem os melhores eles querem
entender que a empresa tem os melhores
trabalhadores aqueles com as melhor
os preços aqueles que os melhores
capacidade de entrega e como que a gente
consegue esses três elementos primeiro o
primeiro elemento é investindo em
tecnologia investir de fato em
tecnologia quanto que a empresa que você
trabalha ou empresa que você tem investe
em melhoria todos os dias o quanto que
melhora os seus processos as suas
rotinas rotina é tudo né Então como que
melhora as suas rotinas como que ela
investe em pessoas para tornar esses
trabalhadores ainda melhores e mais
potentes e Como que essa empresa comenta
busca incentivar que o Brasil se
desenvolva Não no sentido de quantidade
mais um sentido de qualidade com mais a
educação com mais Seguridade com as
pessoas com a maior qualidade de vida
para poder trabalhar melhor então aqui
sim a gente fala de produtividade aqui
sim a gente fala de um trabalhador
satisfeito e com o trabalhador
satisfeito a empresa tem de acolher
melhores resultados Então a gente tem
dois paradigmas a gente tem
o crescimento que a empresa busca a
lucratividade E para isso a gente tem
visto um padrão muito particular que eu
gostaria de chamar atenção que é a
estratégia de não mercado o que que é
estratégia de no mercado quando o
empresário percebe quando as empresas
percebem que tá pouco lucrativa aquele
mercado o que que eles fazem eles
começam a lutar criam associações criam
coletivos e começam a lutar para maiores
intervenções para que o governo né os
governos criem condições para que essa
empresa busque ter uma melhor condição
de Opera E com isso então busca-se então
reduzir o pagamento da folha reduzir
tributos músicas incentivos fiscais os
maiores escândalos de corrupção que a
gente teve no Brasil nos últimos dez
anos 20 Anos 30 anos foram relacionados
a empresas investindo em partidos
políticos porque uma vez que os
políticos se elegiam eles conseguiam é
trazer retorno para essas empresas por
e se beneficiavam então fica estratégia
de não mercado em vez da empresa mudar e
se adaptar para o mercado Esse é melhor
a empresa vai investir envolvendo para
que o governo torna o ambiente melhor
para ela então a gente vê muito um
padrão que é de em vez da empresa olhar
para dentro ela olha muito para fora já
na estratégia na paradigma de
desenvolvimento um cenário em que o
Brasil consegue ser competitivo consegue
se desenvolver como grandes nações a
empresa em vez de tentar mudar o
ambiente ela muda de forma interna e
como que ela vai mudar de forma interno
inovando e novo ano no seu dia a dia nas
suas crenças nas suas rotinas nos seus
processos dos seus produtos Quando foi a
última vez que você teve um produto novo
uma oferta nova Quando foi que você
começou a testar Quando foi que você
começou aproveitar o trabalhador que
você tem dentro da sua empresa para
gerar ideias o Quando foi a última vez
que você adquire um software um sistema
novo para melhorar
e o dia a dia as rotinas da sua empresa
então aqui a gente não tá falando de um
empresário que olha para fora a gente
está falando de uma empresa que olha
para dentro e se adaptar adequadamente
ao mercado Então em vez dela pensar que
ela precisa ganhar dinheiro ela pensa
como eu vou competir para que eu não
tenho a possibilidade de não ganhar
dinheiro porque a minha oferta é melhor
e com isso a gente garante
sustentabilidade Então quais são essas
quatro lições que a gente pode aprender
né A primeira delas é o seguinte que se
você tenta mudar o seu ambiente você tá
tentando mudar uma coisa que é grande
demais que tem muitas variáveis que você
não vai conseguir fazer um exercício
fútil você tentar mudar o ambiente ao
seu favor porque ambiente ele muda o
tempo todo esse ano todo mundo que tava
pensando que a empresa poderia ser a
melhor possível foi pego de surpresa por
uma pandemia de coronavírus mas o que
garante que a gente não vai ter uma
guerra qualquer momento o que garante
que não vai ter um outro surto de doença
é fácil você mudar empresa e você se
adaptar ao ambiente do que você tentar
adaptar o ambiente a sua empresa
e o segundo a segunda lição que a gente
pode aprender é que se a sua empresa
Depende de intervenção do estado para
aliviar reduzindo os seus gastos o seu
negócio provavelmente não é sustentável
e nem competitivo e exatamente esses
elementos que têm sido a base das
pesquisas que eu desenvolvi nos últimos
anos aqui especificamente em Montes
Claros eu fiz em 2015/2016 1718 uma
historiografia do desenvolvimento das
principais indústrias e o resultado que
eu cheguei aqui por muito tempo nós
tivemos uma incidência do que a gente
chama de cemitério de indústrias que no
Imaginário social foram empresas que
vieram para Montes Claros receberão
incentivos fiscais depois que acabou o
incentivo fiscal elas pegaram foram
embora e quando eu fui a fundo nesses
documentos o que que eu descobri que
essas empresas Lutaram muito por esses
incentivos fiscais e quando os
incentivos fiscais acabaram Elas Não
conseguiam competir com o Mercado Chinês
com o mercado norte-americano não
conseguiu com p
o mercado mundial então uma elas foram
quebrando elas foram é perecendo no
mercado Então você tentar fazer com que
o governo crie condições para que o seu
negócio seja sustentável seja lucrativo
é um exercício que no longo prazo não se
sustenta então o seu trabalho muito mais
do que pensar em mudar o ambiente
externo é transformar sua empresa hoje
tornar o seu projeto em preso
competitivo tornar sua oferta a melhor
possível tornar sua oferta Imbatível em
relação ao concorrente a terceira lição
é que o empresário precisa fazer a parte
dele e como um ambiente agora mudou com
coronavírus isso é uma coisa ruim não
veja isso como oportunidade ou seja
existem circunstâncias que o ambiente
muda de a gente precisa mudar também
bom então você precisa ver essa mudança
como algo positivo e pensar em como
solucionar a mudança né como transferir
tecnologias como me tornar parceiros de
empresas que desenvolvem sistemas como
me tornar o parceiro com as
Universidades me aproveitando das
pesquisas das inovações criadas junto a
estudantes eu gosto de dizer que a
universidade é uma república de
estudantes do professor mais titulado ao
aluno que tá começando agora todo mundo
está lá para estudar para conhecer para
pesquisar não existe nada mais bonito em
termos inteligência coletiva Nossa
enquanto humanidade é a gente desses
espaços para a gente aprender para gente
conhecer mais como podemos melhorar
E então como nós podemos fazer essa
transferência de tecnologia de tornarmos
parceiros essas instituições E acima de
tudo não só ficar pensando em quantidade
mas pensar em qualidade porque
crescimento pensa em quantidade de
empresas desenvolvimento pensa na
qualidade da empresa o desenvolvimento
vai vir com aquela empresa que paga bem
o desenvolvimento vai ver com aquela
empresa que contrata o profissional
muito bem informado o desenvolvimento
vai ver com aquela empresa que tem um
bom pacote de oferta o trabalhador
consegue ser feliz com muitas empresas
como é essa nós vamos conseguir nos
desenvolver Então não é só gerar emprego
em quantidade mas gerar empregos de
qualidade também onde as pessoas
trabalham produzem inovam com isso a
empresa competitiva e não tem mercado
que não é dominado pelas empresas mais
competitivas da área EA pergunta que eu
faço é na empresa onde você está na
empresa que você é dono Você tá buscando
é isso é a competitividade e a quarta
lição é que essa
o paradigma ela precisa ser agora e eu
trouxe para vocês algumas matérias
algumas chefia de reportagem Hoje
algumas linhas reportagem Hoje a gente
vê que no meio da pandemia de
coronavírus O mercado consumidor ele é
formado por pessoas que querem
flexibilizar e não querem eu não vou
entrar na questão política aqui se quem
tá certo quem tá errado mas existem
clientes existem consumidores que não
gostam da ideia de voltar para esses
clientes para esses consumidores muitas
matérias aparecem assim empresários
fazem carreata para o desenvolvimento
Olha aí o estado tendo que o empresário
recorrendo ao estado por favor
flexibiliza muda minha vida e o seu
cliente está vendo isso o seu cliente
está percebendo isso
se você quer ser essa empresa ou você
quer ser essa que sai nas matérias
reportagens como sete empresas que estão
inovando durante a pandemia durante a
crise sete empresas que reaprender ão
como fazer empresas começam a melhorar
começa a enriquecer o trabalho começam
achar formas diferentes no meio da
pandemia qual foi qual foi a forma de
Conduta mudar acompanhar um ambiente ser
competitivo melhorar ou tentar mais uma
vez intervir precisar mais uma vez de um
Estado em uma economia de propósito
liberal em uma Economia em que a gente
presta pelas liberdades a gente precisa
prezar também pela competição então meu
conselho para quem tá aí do outro lado é
o seguinte a melhor receita que você
pode dar para empresa onde você trabalha
ou para empresa que você é dono é tornar
essa empresa competitiva não só pensar
no lucro mas pensar o
a empresa agrega em tempo de competição
quanto que você é melhor que o seu
concorrente para isso não olhe para fora
para entender o que tá acontecendo mas
trabalho do lado de dentro Então essa é
a minha mensagem e eu convido a vocês a
pensar em si Na Busca Pela lucratividade
você de fato tá vivendo que a realidade
da empresa que a tornando ela melhor
competitiva de maior valor não seja a
pessoa que busca o título e esquece de
aprender seja aquela pessoa que lucra
fazendo o dever de casa e sabendo que tá
fazendo dentro da empresa é isso
obrigado